Since we're using dynamic programming
the first thing we look for
is some optimal similar substructure.
Recall that the key realization in
understanding the single source shortest
path algorithms like Dijkstra and
Bellman Ford was that subpath of
shortest paths are our shortest path.
So if this is a shortest path between U
V and it happens to go between X and Y.
Then the subpath must be
a shortest path between X and Y.
If there were a shorter one,
then it could replace this subpath in
the path from U to V, and that would
then give us a shorter path from U to V.
This type of argument is called cut and
paste for obvious reasons.
By the way, throughout,
I'll use squiggly lines to indicate
the path between two vertices, and
straight ones to indicate a single edge.
Unfortunately, by itself,
this structure is not enough.
Sure, we might be able to argue
that a shortest path from U to V
must take a shortest path from
U to a neighbor of V first, but
how do we find the shortest path?
The sub problems end up
having circular dependencies.
One idea is to include
the notion of path length,
defined by the number of edges used.
If we knew all shortest path that
only used k minis one edges,
then by examining the neighbors of V,
we could figure out the shortest
path with K edges to V.
We'll let delta U V F K be
the weight of the shortest path
that uses at most K edges.
Then the recurrence is that delta U V K
is the minimum of delta U V K minus one.
This is where we don't use
that potential kth edge.
Or it's the minimum of
the distances from.
U to one of the neighbors of V
using only k minus one edges.
Plus the weight of that
last edge to get us to V.
This strategy works, and it yields
the matrix multiplication shortest path
algorithm that runs in
time V cubed log V.
See Cormen, Leiserson,
Rivest, Stein for details.
We're going to take a different approach
that will yield a slightly faster
algorithm, and
allow us to remove this log factor.
We're going to recurse on the the set
of potential intermediate vertices
used in the shortest path.
Without loss of generality, we'll assume
that the vertices are one through N for
the convenience of notation,
consider the last step of the algorithm,
where we've allowed vertices one
through N to be intermediate vertices.
And just now we're considering
the effect of allowing
N to be an intermediate vertex.
Clearly our choices either
using the old path, or
taking the shortest path from U to N.
And then from N to V.
In fact, this is the choice not just for
N, but for any K between one and N.
To get from U to V using only
intermediate vertices one through K,
we can either use K by taking these
shortest paths, or not use it.
Therefore, we define delta U V F K,
to be the minimum weight
of a path from U to V.
Using only one through K as
the intermediate vertices.
Then, the recurrence
becomes delta U V F K.
Is the minimum of delta U V K
minus one that is not using K.
That is an intermediate vertex.
And using K that is taking the shortest
allowed path to K from U and
then going as quickly as
possible from K to V.
In the base case where no intermediate
vertices are allowed the weights and
the edges provide all
the needed information.